you
mr. dragon is the guy who got it
number 39 was that difficult number
let's try the benoni and let's actually
go forward with the Benko
there was a game from the zurich 1953
tournament with the Bronston playing as
black and he turned the clocks back
quite a bit for that theory has evolved
quite quite a bit but uh I don't know
since since looking through that game
again I started to play the Benko a
little bit so it's not being accepted so
should I just capture now I still leave
it there there's this idea I've seen
played well now maybe since the knight
is threatening to capture maybe I don't
let's let's do this first
not sure if it's best okay so I'm gonna
go with the kingside fiend cat I'll
maybe I'll look to do this take out this
Knight
all right
let's see
um I'm quite tempted to push here where
does that Knight go he's got to go back
home hmm
all right let's go with this I could
have just considered this move oh I
should have considered that no although
after Queen c2 yeah
all right let's castle avoid well just
protect my bishop get developed and this
is the direction I want to go I want to
bring him up here maybe even look to do
this not because it looks good visually
but because it is good they would kick
this bishop off the diagonal then he
turns into the big bad wolf so I'm
thinking Bishop g4 or run my pawn up
here let's run I have a space
disadvantage here in the center I'm an
advantage on the Queen side so this is
where I ought to be playing well I
didn't come to a5 to just sit there so
let's follow through now what move the
rook so the bishop if I play h3 the
bishop has to go there whoa well that's
different
let's take care
then take care kick the bishop off this
diagonal and then do something with this
guy this Knight can't do too much wheres
where's he going I can't do this and
expect to recapture the night because
I'd be pinned so let me go here so
checking opportunities not really so the
bishop is inconvenienced and I really I
don't know that I would find a great
purpose for my LightSquared bishop so
let me make sure I could get rid of him
so he's in a pen and I'm gonna keep him
in a pen until the question is thrown to
me with age three or maybe if Bishop e2
is played but until that happens I'm not
going to do anything but I did have to
do something and now I think it would be
a good idea to put some pressure on this
night because I'd really like to play
here and give check and win this Bishop
I think
white has to return white isn't
returning okay I think my knight will
find a nice home on this square you know
I think I'm quite welcome to dark square
bishop exchange that was get my rook
working dr. bishop exchange would mean
my knight kids is here for forever maybe
actually he needs to get out of the way
and I could jump in here next he's kind
of stuck having only one square in it
that's his home square let's jump in
here for some exchanges I might want to
capture like this yes I definitely want
to capture like this get this past pond
and I have a nice home for my knight on
c5 my queen has also opened up we're
likely going to enter an opposite color
bishop ending let me let me be annoying
somehow let me be annoying okay rook
here it's needed yeah this might be
quite difficult here because I don't
know how maybe I should have considered
this my rook after my clients going very
fast and that's a good like it's tough
to break down it's tough to get in b3
these guys are really watching over that
everything oh this is actually working
out though I get some activity a lot of
it queen striking here on g1 that was my
idea and that works now what's the
follow-up
what is that follow-up uh where's the
knockout here it's not so easy no it's
not think I could actually still trade
and have an attack on the dark squares
my opponent has a light square structure
so he's h2f two squares if I have to
eliminate some piece here to do
something I couldn't also considered
Queen here maybe I mean I was too quick
to do that and it probably was should
have kept another piece on the board
this Queen goes too far away there's
some technical tactical opportunities
against this guy and that's that's
actually not working as I could take and
I could take here this punish past I
have an eye on it I could take care
that's with check my rook is indirectly
guarding that how about I capture that
maybe if it's not captured will be mate
sneakiness
all right let me just let's do this
get some checks in this is a difficult
position with opposite color bishops
whoa I really don't want to trade maybe
I should have you guys should have I'm
not even sure what I'm doing at that
move okay I'm also not sure what I'm
doing at that move okay okay I win that
pawn oh they're getting it oh I got the
Queen ah
they were just they're just stuck on
doing what they flinched at the attack I
had on the poem Wow
I had plenty of time this is this is
plenty of time just make sure nothing
can move here this game over there's no
opportunity for stalemate even where is
the mate many different mates
clean somewhere here next yeah that um
man that was tough I don't if I didn't
have the if you didn't push that pond
nice that's a good game man
I mean I was I was up that pond I had
activity but I couldn't really see a
great way to get at your king I had the
past pawn but it was blockaded let's go
back here I have seen this before yes I
guess some type of decline version of
the Benko I don't know how great this
move is but I I know that after after
white does capture there is a sick so I
figured I'd just do a six right now I
certainly don't want to allow the knight
to take the Bangko game it is when you
are forcing the C pawn to become a
knight pond there be pond
I wonder if at this point you have an
opportunity right here at this point
right here I wonder if you can go
forward with a for right now and try to
just say you know what you have a space
advantage on the queenside I recognize
that I don't want you to be playing
there and so maybe you could stop me
cold with a for right now knowing the
following thing if I if I'm to capture
you could be recapturing with the night
and then I'll have to be concerned about
a piece on this B 5 squared
maybe it's an idea a timely a four move
before I'm playing a for myself and you
could only go forward with of course a
single step so that's an interesting
alternative because if you lock down
again
on the queenside I really can't make use
of my activity my space advantage on
that side and then the attention will
immediately shift towards the center
where you have an advantage this pawn on
d5 is face advantage in the center so
that's an that's a that would be
interesting I think with how things
turned out here actually I'm wondering
about maybe at this point instead of
immediately recapturing you could maybe
think about pushing or not pushing but
capturing I would be recapturing is this
pot of be for a liability or an asset is
the big question to ask on top of that
you would be allowing my knight to have
a nice post on the c5 square so there
are some pros and cons with this
particular capture so we have those
exchanges I wanted to make sure I get
rid of that Bishop I'm I'm pretty sure
at this point on those side who has an
advantage if you're not going to be
threatening to get in the e5 advance
then I could hide there there's nothing
for you to attack right the structure of
the structure side of things the e7 is
my most vulnerable point but it's it's
very hard to get out
and he's a weak link this this is a
difficult structure the seafloor upon
and after watch over him although I
didn't really put so much pressure on
him you finally do get your pawns
rolling and you do give up that I wonder
if it was the correct decision to be
capturing at the pond I was the two
things I liked this but the my primary
reason I really liked being able to get
my knight in here but you know what come
to think of it maybe I should avoid the
knight exchange maybe I could drop my
knight in to b2 or maybe even get him
here maybe the bishop move wasn't even
necessary yeah you know what maybe maybe
on the black side I could try to drop a
knight in to c3 and he's probably going
to be much more a pest much more of a
pest but how do i how do I get any
activity snidey he's a tough guy he's
definitely a tough guy mate maybe I
could look to target this pawn hmm I'm
not sure I wasn't seeing anything
opposite color Bishop ending so oops
is the computer gonna be finding
something that's a quick kill here I
certainly wasn't seeing yeah I know that
this push wasn't a good idea but I
certainly had my concerns on the clock
and physician because you establish a
past seep on I I went upon this
variation is there something better for
me to play besides rook here and just
want to quickly look I don't know I
thought about this to get another pawn
involved controlling squares near the
King Bob I just wasn't really seeing how
to really get at the King any further I
do have a bishop check but after King
here
oh maybe that's it Bishop check King
here queen h2 I come around like the
back door there
Bishop II won Queen h2 that's gotta be
good if I could if I could plant mic
hang on like my king my queen on g3 it's
gonna be tough for the King I did think
about this but I guess I just wasn't
seeing the follow up queen h2 to g3
seems to be quite strong we didn't have
that I went upon but opposite color
Bishop ending how do I it's it's like
I'm playing without this pawn if I can't
dislodge the Bishop and it's just tough
it's very tough I don't know I don't
know what more to say if this planning
the end up dropping maybe there was too
much focus on well I know that you were
focused on the pond but I was the side I
you know what it felt like to be
perfectly honest just some practical
advice it felt like I don't know if it's
true but it felt like you're trying to
burn my time and you were the side who
really had the time to think you know
but it felt that I don't know if that's
really how it was but it seemed like it
the pace kind of picked up when I was
getting much lower on time you were in a
you're in a good position so use that
use that time available because I think
you had some serious threats if if this
if you were able to get in this pawn to
c6
we both have passed pawns but yours
seems more dangerous okay I could be
controlling it but I don't know I was I
wasn't seeing any checkmate against the
king of it was a tough tough game first
time I were playing I believed as well
anyhow alrighty
good game mr. mr. dragon